بعد اكثر من 10 اشهر على بدء الحرب
الاوكرانيه تصعيد الدبلوماسي لافته بين
موسكو وكيف
اوكرانيا دعت الدول الاعضاء في الامم
المتحده لحرمان روسيا الاتحاديه من وضعها
كعضو دائم في مجلس الامن الدولي
واستبعادها كليا من الامم المتحده مطلب لا
فرص له للنجاح وفقا لمراقبين
تصريحات اوكرانيه يقابلها تهديد ووعيد
الروسيه جاء على لسان وزير الخارجيه
السيرغي لافراف الذي غير المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين بين تنفيذ المقترحات الروسيه
بنزع السلاح او ان يحسم الجيش الروسي
الامر وتوعد الوزير لافراف كيف بطول امد
الحرب اوكرانيا اعلنت قبل ذلك انها تهدف
الى عقد قمه السلام بحلول نهايه فبراير
المقبل
وفي اول رد للكريم على مقترحي كيف قال
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه دي متر
بيسكوف ان موسكو لم تتبع ابدا شروط
الاخرين بل تلتزم فقط باهدافها الخاصه